la france on le sait est très en retard
en ce qui concerne les équipements
informatiques mais paradoxalement pour
internet c'est exactement l'inversé
plus de cinq millions de français sont
déjà content connecter au réseau mondial
et le nombre d'abonnements augmente en
flèche s'ils pourraient être 10 ou 20
fois plus important dans cinq ans
valérie battle christian carnet internet
c'est la révolution de l'information et
des télécommunications
ces deux mondes se côtoyaient
aujourd'hui ils ont totalement fusionnée
ils ont fait naître une toile d'araignée
mondiale la plus grande autoroute de
l'information en matière d'équipements
informatiques la france rattrape son
retard par rapport à ses voisins 20
millions de foyers sont équipés de micro
ordinateurs et plus de 5 millions de
personnes en surfer sur internet en 99
en 2003 ce chiffre pourrait être
multiplié par quatre avec 20 millions
d'internautes
témoin de ce redémarrage en trombe le
changement de comportement des
consommateurs
d'abord à la recherche d'informations
ils deviennent de fervents accros du
commerce électronique
ou est-ce qu'on anticipe une
accélération parce que on sent qu'ils
passent de plus en plus d'heures sur
internet a aujourd'hui l'internaute
moyen dans les foyers passe plus disert
sur internet par mois et ça augmente
toutes les semaines et derrière cet
apprentissage on sent bien que derrière
ils vont découvrir comment gagner du
temps en achetant sur internet
d'ailleurs le chiffre d'affaires de ces
achats en ligne et de 9 milliards de
francs
99 en 2003 il atteindrait les 280
milliards
un beau pactole pour les sociétés qui
utiliseront une porte d'accès sur
internet
du coup un autre défi s'annonce
généraliser l'accès au réseau par
n'importe quel moyen
bienvenue dans un monde sans fille
enlevée